hasta el momento lo que he hecho del
producto cruz y el producto punto te he
dado definiciones hemos hecho algunos
ejemplos y bueno ya sea que tomas el
coseno o el seno del ángulo entre ellos
pero qué pasa si no te dan el vector
visualmente qué pasa si no te dan el
ángulo entre ellos cómo vas a calcular
el producto punto o el producto cruz
pongo nuevamente las definiciones
digamos que tengo yo aquí aa punto b eso
es lo mismo que la magnitud del vector a
por la magnitud del vector b por el
coseno del ángulo entre ellos ahora bien
entonces a cruz b es igual a la magnitud
de an por la magnitud de b por el seno
del ángulo entre ellos es decir
proyecciones perpendiculares por el
vector normal el cual es perpendicular a
ambos vectores y donde en el cual
averiguamos su dirección usando la regla
de la mano derecha pero y si no tenemos
esto definido visualmente que qué sucede
si no tenemos los ángulos por ejemplo a
qué pasaría si yo te doy
vector am en notación de ingeniería es
decir que bueno en esta anotación
simplemente divides al vector en sus
componentes x y z
entonces el vector a digamos que es
igual a 55 y donde ahí es el vector
unitario que va en la dirección de x
luego menos 6 j menos 6 j más fresca y
jk son simplemente los vectores
unitarios en las direcciones x y y ceta
respectivamente el 5 indica cuánto
avanza en la dirección de x el menos 6
indica cuánto va en la dirección de jay
el 3 indica cuánto va en la dirección de
z de hecho puedes graficar lo y es que
bueno si las gráficas tendrás más
intuición claro pero digamos que esto es
todo lo que se te dan y ahora lo toca el
sector ve para un bebé ok el bm el bebé
bueno simplemente me estoy inventando
números digamos que es menos 2
y estamos en tres dimensiones claro más
7-j y más 4k más cuatro camps puedes
graficar los de hecho si se te diera un
problema si quisieras modelar vectores
en un simulador así es como le harías
simplemente rompes el vector en sus
componentes x 6 zeta y aquí simplemente
sumas cierto pero como multiplicas como
los multiplicas ya sea tomando el
producto cruzo el producto punto no lo
voy a probar aquí pero voy a estar pero
te voy a mostrar cómo se hace el
producto punto es muy sencillo con esta
anotación esta anotación también se
puede escribir de la siguiente manera
con corchetes entonces sería 5 menos 6 y
y entonces solamente son las magnitudes
de los de las direcciones x jay-z y este
el b sería menos 2 7 y 4 así que pasemos
a lo siguiente como hago yo para el
producto punto entre a y b a punto b a
bueno de hecho esto va a ser hasta algo
placentero porque es muy sencillo
ahorita va a saber por qué digo esto
sucede que lo único que haces es
multiplicar los componentes de y se los
sumas a los componentes de j
multiplicados y eso se los sumas a los
componentes de cada multiplicados
entonces esto es igual a 5 x 5 x menos 2
más
menos 6 por 7 menos 6 por 7 más
3 por 4 3 por 4 y esto es igual a menos
10 menos 42 más 12 lo cual es igual a
menos 52 más 12 que es igual a menos 40
y ahí lo tienes ese es un número de
hecho aquí yo de curiosa sería muy bueno
graficar esto ver ver por qué o cómo o
por qué es menos 40 quizás van en
direcciones opuestas sus proyecciones
quién sabe
entonces como puedes ver es fácil de
calcularlo de esta manera sale directo
porque lo único que estamos haciendo es
multiplicar los componentes de x estos
dos componentes las multiplicas las
sumas a la multiplicación de las
componentes de jay y eso los sumas a la
multiplicación de las componentes de
zeta
eso es todo como puedes ver si te dan
los vectores en esta anotación es
bastante fácil calcular el producto
punto pero como puedes ver tomar el
producto cruz de estos vectores en esta
anotación no es tan directo aunque claro
tenemos variedad y eso es lo bueno
porque otra manera de hacerlo sería
averiguar la magnitud de cada uno de
estos vectores y luego usar
trigonometría elegante para averiguar
los ángulos y después usar la definición
pero creo que te gusta bastante el hecho
de que sea más sencillo de esta forma el
producto punto es algo bastante
divertido ahora haremos veremos si
podemos tomar el producto cruz y no lo
voy a demostrar simplemente te enseñaré
cómo se hace en un vídeo futuro si me lo
piden aunque bueno no lo voy a demostrar
en un vídeo futuro así que ok hagamos
esto del producto cruz para tomar el
producto cruz de los vectores en esta
anotación
entonces ok a cruz b es una aplicación
de matrices lo que haces es tomar el
determinante esto es sólo una manera de
para facilitarte la vida es una manera
para que memorice es lo que estás
haciendo lo que se hace aquí no te da
tanta intuición pero la intuición te la
da la definición recuerda lo que
hacíamos multiplicamos las magnitudes
usa la regla de la mano derecha y esto
te dice
dirección apunta al vector normal cierto
pero qué pasa si te dan esta anotación
entonces lo que haces es escribir los
vectores unitarios y jk en el primer
renglón luego escribe es el primer
vector del producto cruz porque bueno el
orden si importa aquí así que es 5 menos
6 y 3 luego tomas el segundo vector b es
menos 2 7 y 4 tomas determinante de esta
matriz de 3 por 3 entonces esto sería
igual al sub determinante para y así que
quitas esta columna y quitas este
renglón te queda menos 6
7 y 4 x y si no recuerdas determinantes
tal vez esto te sirva bueno yo creo que
te sirve mucho como un repaso cierto
entonces recuerda que es más menos más
así que aquí tenemos menos el sub
determinante para j y cuál es el sub
determinante para j quizás aquí cruzas
la columna y la fila de j entonces
tienes 5 tiene 53 menos 2 y 4 53 menos 2
y 4 sólo quitamos la columna y el
renglón de j
estos son los números de su sub
determinante para j más el sub
determinante para acá le sumamos el sub
determinante para acá quitamos las
columnas la columna y la fila para acá
entonces nos queda 5 menos 65 menos seis
menos 2 y 7 por acá baja ahora
calculamos los determinantes haré un
poco de espacio aquí voy a borrar
algunas cosas no ya no ya no lo
necesitamos
que borró esto adiós y adiós también
entonces que obtenemos bueno lo voy a
hacer aquí arriba estos determinantes de
2 por 2 son bastante sencillos de
realizar cierto entonces menos seis por
cuatro menos 7 por 3 entonces menos 24
menos 21 - 24 menos 21 por y menos 5 por
4 es 20 entonces 20 menos menos dos por
tres serían menos menos 6 j menos menos
6 j más 5 por 7 35 menos menos dos por
menos seis es 12 entonces es menos 12
por acá y ahora lo simplificamos esto es
igual a menos 24 - 21 eso es menos 45
y luego 20 menos menos 6 es igualdad
entonces menos 26 j
-26 j después 35 menos 12 eso es más 23
acá y ahí lo tienes el producto cruz si
graficar asestó en tres dimensiones tú
podrías ver y bueno eso es lo
interesante del asunto tú podrías
observar y as este vector menos 45 y
menos 26 j más 23 acá que es totalmente
perpendicular a ambos vectores a y b en
el próximo vídeo voy a intentar obtener
algún programa para graficar bueno
porque va a ser divertido de hecho vamos
a calcular el producto cruz y el
producto punto usando estos métodos que
te acabo de mostrar y graficar hemos y
te mostraré también que si funciona esto
así que bueno también te voy a mostrar
que este vector es totalmente
perpendicular a a y b y es el vector que
te indica usando la regla de la mano
derecha así que nos vemos